[Music]  you are like the Internet's favorite  piece of man-meat from this season I my  at my my ass was out a little bit um you  know I mean I'm a bigger guy I'm I do  bodybuilding competitions so I'm used to  having my body exposed and I may have  been a little fluffy the season but I  mean I really didn't you just like I  love being in the Sun and I love having  my ass out and tanning and I wasn't too  concerned with clearly wasn't concerned  at all with what was gonna be put on the  Internet  well ya know I mean I I hope I hope  America enjoyed it I really I hope they  enjoyed it I think they dan and woman  everybody Equal Opportunity ass looking  yes exactly  [Music]  you